you know what I always tell myself man
if only I was born earlier so I could
have bought real estate at the bottom
during 2011 or damn it mom and dad why
can I have been born earlier so I could
have been part of the dot-com boom who
knows maybe I could have been a
millionaire today or maybe even a
billionaire and if you felt the same
then you've come to the right place
because today we're going over one of
those little-known industries that's on
the verge of exploding so call now for
just 12 easy payments of $2,500 whoo
that was that was pretty crunchy in all
seriousness here's the thing we all look
back on all the opportunities we missed
out on and think why didn't I just jump
in when tick tock wasn't the number-one
social media platform but hindsight is
20/20 what if there were other
industries like the real estate boom
like the dot-com boom like the mobile
app boom where millionaires were
literally minted overnight they're
happening right now now maybe you could
take advantage of to make you Millions
where you could be the one on top ten
years in the future instead of sitting
at home wishing that you got on the
train that is exactly what this new
series is about the big underground
industry is happening right now that are
just on the very edge of exploding into
trillions of dollars so sit back relax
and welcome to the quantum gold rush
[Music]
in 1956 to store just five megabytes of
data you needed a hard drive the size of
an extra large commercial refrigerator
today we can affordably hold over 51,000
times that amount on the tip of our
finger but as engineers and
entrepreneurs kept pushing the
boundaries of what's possible with
computing we keep getting diminishing
returns within the last few years to put
that into perspective in 1984 the u.s.
got its first real consumer mobile
phones the Motorola DynaTAC 8000x it had
a price tag of nearly four thousand
dollars or nearly ten thousand dollars
in today's money a weight of two pounds
and a 10 hour charge time for just 30
minutes of talk even though those specs
are ancient by today's standards
everything about it was a giant leap for
it and nothing short of revolutionary in
2007 we got the revolutionary iPhone
where every single aspect of what we
knew about a phone evolved and was
completely reimagined what's the effect
of that pull the cell phone out of your
pocket it has more memory than the all
the memory made for every computer in
the world in 1970 and you buy it for one
millionth the cost of one computer at
that time and in 2020 we're gonna get an
iPhone with the revolutionary feature of
having one les portes yeah things are
starting to slow down and in the
computer world it's pretty much the same
sure computers are getting faster year
by year but we're not seeing that
exponential strides we had in previous
years in previous decades this means
that the one technology that powers our
entire modern day lives that's at the
core of every million-dollar business
every billion-dollar business every
brick-and-mortar business education
government you name it is at a plateau
or in other words Humanity is at a
bottleneck and the person or group that
can figure out a new way to keep pushing
Humanity forward forget millionaire
forget even billionaire there'll be one
of the most pivotal people in all of
human history enter quantum computing
[Music]
here is the most simple explanation you
will find of quantum computing on the
Internet
to understand what allows quantum
computing to potentially break this
computational plateau or that we have to
know a tiny bit about classical
computers also known as the computers at
your desk and in your pocket all
classical computers at their core or
made up of bits and each bit can be
either 0 or 1
you can think of bits like our number
system but instead of 0 to 9 numbers
it's just 0 to 1 and just like our
number system once we count up to 9 we
run out of numbers so to continue
counting what do we do we set the next
column as 1 and reset the current column
as 0 and you get the number 10 when we
get to the max of 2 columns or the
number 99 we do the same thing we set
the third column as 1 we reset the first
to a 0 and the process continues and for
computers is exactly the same but we
just have 2 numbers in each column we
count from 0 to 1 then we run out of
numbers so we add another column or
another bit set that to 1 and reset the
current bit as 0 and the process
continues string a bunch of bits
together and you get a bigger number
string eight bits together and you can
represent a letter string multiple eight
bits together and you get words if we
string an incomprehensible amount of
bits together you get the ability to
compare yourself to others on Instagram
and to do other nefarious stuff on these
things called computers but the problem
with computers being set up like this is
that we're getting to the point where
we're getting to the physical limits of
how many bits we can squeeze together
onto a single computer chip and thus
classical computer growth is starting to
plateau so what does this all mean it's
coming to an end are we going to have
computers in the future well we're
certainly investing in research it is
really research it's things going on in
laboratories that physicists are working
on to try to invent new computers this
is where quantum computers are supposed
to come in instead of just bits
representing zeros and ones or just two
states or two possibilities thanks to
some wizardry in quantum physics that is
outside the scope of this video each bit
in a quantum computer or equipment can
represent either 0 or 1
at the same time that is literally all
that separates classical computers from
fancy quantum ones more possible states
equals more possible data that can be
processed the classical bit stores
information as a zero or one and a
quantum bit can be both zero and one at
the same time if you have two quantum
bits then there are four possible states
that you can put in superposition with
three cubits it's eight four qubits at
16 but grows exponentially and with just
a small difference alone it allows
quantum computers to scale up
exponentially bigger and faster and be
able to compete way more information
with a fewer number of bits compared to
classical computers we're talking
computing something that would take
current supercomputers that range in the
hundreds of millions of dollars 10,000
years to compute in something like 3
minutes and 20 seconds or in other words
just like the revolution cars computers
and an internet broth for quantum
computers have the potential to change
the world as we know it and what massive
change comes massive massive money but
what does that change look like
[Music]
artificial intelligence has been said to
be to the 21st century what electricity
was that the 20th century and at its
core AI learns through experience
Facebook's picture tagging facial
recognition software is so accurate
because Facebook's AI has pored through
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
pictures to learn how to recognize faces
and it's these constant repetitive
calculations that makes AI the perfect
candidate for the power of quantum
computing a few real-life examples of
this include Lockheed Martin planning to
use quantum computers to test their auto
pilot software that's too complex to
test on a classical machine Google is
also planning on using quantum computers
for even more complex image recognition
tasks another use case that will be very
interesting see is using quantum
computers in the financial markets to
predict where prices will go which is a
lot harder to do right now due to the
practically infinite amount of
possibilities that can happen in the
markets the cryptography that keeps your
pictures passwords credit card
information and other nefarious stuff
that you keep on your computer secure is
another industry that's going to be
heavily disrupted because quantum
computers can simply break the current
math equations that cryptography uses
where classical computers couldn't it's
so bad that the NSA is actively
developing quantum resistant
cryptographic algorithms that won't be
able to be beaten by quantum computers
and these are just some of the early use
cases that scientists think quantum
computers will be good for others
include weather forecasting molecular
modeling particle physics and the list
just goes on and on but who knows when
phones first came onto the scene most
people imagined it would only ever be
used for talking to other people no one
could have ever imagined that one day
not too long into the future
phones will be able to surf this thing
called the Internet that it would serve
as a platform for this mini economy
called mobile apps did you know you can
order a life-size cutout of Danny DeVito
and I predict the business of quantum
computers will be the same first it will
only be used at the scientific and big
business level and as the technology
progresses it will slowly trickle down
to the consumer and who knows maybe one
day we'll even have quantum computers in
our smartphones the only problem is we
don't know how to make a practical
quantum computer yet
meet Google as if they couldn't get any
more powerful they've been pushing a ton
of money into creating a viable quantum
computer and on October 23rd they
achieved a fancy term called quantum
supremacy basically where they were able
to compute a problem that would take
10,000 years to compute on a classical
computer and do it in just three minutes
and 20 seconds although their competitor
IBM claims the same task could have been
done in just 2.5 days on a classical
supercomputer scientists say that
Google's achievement is the modern-day
equivalent of the Wright brothers first
flight back in 1903 Google and IBM are
alone though Microsoft Amazon Alibaba
Huawei and plenty of other startups have
joined the party in this modern-day Gold
Rush the quantum supremacy Amazon is
partnering what other starts to have
their own quantum computer and making it
available through the cloud IBM have
their IBM Q initiative which is a
community that's developing quantum
software already as we speak and just
like the waves of yesterday private
investors and venture capitalists are
starting to pour more and more money
into this arena in hopes of getting that
first mover's advantage the gold rush is
on so I want to leave you with one final
thought Apple was able to become the
biggest company in the world nearly a
trillion dollars with just classical
computers so how high will quantum take
us
[Music]
thank you so much for being part of the
watch the end Club and be sure to let me
know what you think of this new series
of like looking into future businesses
and industries because I really do read
all of your else's feedback and I base
that feedback on what to make next and
if you enjoy the style hopefully
visually pleasing videos for the
business entrepreneurs side of things a
few pixels below the screen there's a
little button it's red and it says
subscribe and if you click it number one
it really please the YouTube guys which
will help me out a ton and number two
you can get more videos just like this
one for free every single week so you
might as well just click that red button
down below right now along with the belt
icon so you get notified whenever I
released a new video and as always you
can always disliked and unsub whenever
you want so you literally have nothing
to lose that is gonna wrap up this video
you can follow me on Instagram I Jake
trend dot IO thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one oh and Happy Holidays to
[Music]